were you thinking that they were going  to hurt you yeah attack you constantly I  don't know these men so we what was a  dialog in your head about that  well how do I get them to shoot me and  just shoot me instead of dismembering me  or raping me how do i how do I do that  what can I do that will actually create  that and I could never actually come up  with a strategy for that if I ran oh I  think that would just make them angry  and I think I would probably get treated  pretty badly if I tried to run and where  are you running to by the way there's no  place to run yeah there isn't because  I'm also told there are many other rebel  groups out in this area that we're in so  you thought if something bad is going to  happen you're thinking please let it  happen quickly yes